Volcanic eruptions can last for weeks, months,
or even years.
This violent event is terrifying.
But what if another storm say a tornado
or a hurricane combined with a volcanic eruption?
Could it really happen?
How long would it last?
And if a volcano and a tornado combined,
what could it throw at you?
This is what if,
and here's what would happen if a tornado hidden active volcano
tornadoes only form during giant thunderstorms called super cells.
And according to George Karuna's storm chaser and host of angry
planet, super cells are already frightening.
So the biggest storms on planet earth there,
I've seen ones that have been twice the height of Mount Everest.
All of that energy rotating around produces torrential flooding,
hail to the size of baseball or larger vicious lightning.
And that rotation can come all the way to the ground and produce massive.
Tornadoes.
Could one of these massive tornadoes strike an active volcano.
Let's back up a bit. Before we get into the details,
we need to visit the basics for a tornado to happen.
You need just the right ingredients.
When you're trying to forecast a tornado,
you have to try and make a three dimensional picture of the atmosphere from the
ground all the way up, almost a space, the moisture humidity,
wind patterns, wind shear, all of these different ingredients.
And if something is off just ever so slightly, it just wrecks the whole recipe.
So what are those ingredients? Well,
first you need an updraft which can happen when cold air comes in and
shoves, warm air, higher into the atmosphere.
Then you need winds to change direction at different atmospheric Heights.
As the warm air rises, it starts to spin.
If there's enough spin,
then that column of air rotates until it makes contact with the ground.
And now you have a tornado
volcanoes form when magma escapes from Earth's core through a
crack in Earth's crust, in some volcanoes,
the magma is too thick and traps gas bubbles.
Eventually this creates so much pressure that the volcano blows its top.
But according to George, there is a lot less unknown about the earth score.
If you were to shrink the earth down to about the size of an Apple,
the crust portion would be about as thick as the skin.
And we have never gone deep enough to do more than even just scratch the surface
of that skin.
Usually these two natural phenomenon don't happen in the same
geographical location.
There aren't many volcanoes in tornado alley after all,
but there are places where the possibility of the two colliding become
more of a reality.
Italy surprisingly gets quite a few tornadoes. As a matter of fact,
one was reported there just the other day.
So we've got a place you're in Europe,
where they get tornadoes from time to time and they also have
active volcanoes. Mount Etna is active all the time. Mt.
Stromboli is erupting today,
erupts every single day and has been doing so for 2000 years.
All right.
So let's say that the largest tornado ever documented is going to hit
Mount Vesuvius, which is the volcano that destroyed the city of Pompei.
What would this catastrophe look like?
So if you had a tornado that big,
as strong as tornadoes get between 250 to 300 plus miles an
hour,
air starts to basically starts to act like a solid it's
so powerful.
So you take that and you combine that with a volcano.
This tornado would pick up fire smoke and Ash from the volcano,
creating a spinning vortex from hell.
We've got sulfur gas. You have volcanic Ash,
which is microscopic shards of assaulted glass,
just the Ash alone,
being whipped at those speeds would sand blast your skin completely
off of your body in seconds.
It's a level of destruction that is difficult for the human brain to
comprehend.
But what about the lava lava is melted rock
and it's three times denser than water. So it's quite heavy.
Different kinds of volcanoes. Eject lava have different thicknesses.
Mount Vesuvius is a straddle volcano,
which means it's made up of many layers of hardened, magma, volcanic,
Ash and material created from volcanic eruptions called TEFRA
strata. Volcanoes have slow moving lava that hardens before it spreads very far.
Unfortunately,
straddle volcanoes also tend to erupt violently.
Through the eruption of the Soviets. Back in, back in Roman times,
it was a plenty interruption was a style of rupture where you have these massive
explosions. You have rocks, you got chunks of lava.
Now they're being whipped around by 300 mile per hour winds.
So we're talking the worst place in the world to be.
And that's not all like a fire tornado. Uh,
love a NATO would spread hot Ash and magma over the surrounding area,
setting it a blaze golf ball sized hail debris and
hardened lava could rip through trees, buildings, cars,
its core could reach temperatures of 1093 degrees
burning. Anything. It touches to a crisp.
Is possible that a tornado could strike a volcano. Like this would be this big.
The odds are infinitesimally small, but it's not zero.
Well that's good news. But what about a volcano? Creating its own tornado?
Volcanoes are so powerful that they can create their own weather
as a volcano spews, hot gases and molten lava.
The surrounding temperature increases rapidly.
This forces cold air to rise and stretch out into a column,
creating a massive cloud formation.
Something similar happened in 2020 and the California wildfires.
I'll let George explain.
During the California wildfires,
we had an interesting situation where the fire was so intense
that the heat coming off of fire created an updraft that formed what we call a
pyro Cumulus cloud. The cloud grew so big. It turned into a thunder storm,
a pyro cumulonimbus cloud, and then it started to spin.
So now we had this super cell funder storm that was literally created
by the wildfire and that storm produced.
And do you have three tornado?
So hypothetically something similar could happen over a volcano
as it creates its own weather.
And if the wind over a volcano suddenly changes direction and
increases in speed,
the column of colder air could begin to rotate creating a
tornado. Thankfully,
this destructive storm has a short lifespan like a normal
tornado. The lava NATO would only last around 20 minutes.
It would also have a limited range because it's created by the unique
weather hovering over a volcano. It wouldn't be able to travel very far.
Once the Lavin NATO moves away from the volcanoes hot gases,
it would start to break up,
but the fires had started would still be raging.
Okay. We've talked a lot about tornadoes and volcanoes,
but what would happen if a hurricane hit an active volcano,
hurricanes are much larger and longer lasting than tornadoes with a
horizontal reach of over 1600 kilometers and wind speeds up to
252 kilometers per hour.
It's much more likely that an active volcano and a hurricane would combine,
but surprisingly not much would happen other than the normal
destruction caused by hurricane.
That is because a hurricane is so much larger than a volcano.
They would have very little effect on each other.
If the active volcano is large enough and we're talking massive here,
it could make the hurricane bigger and stronger and the
hurricane could spread the volcanoes dangerous, volcanic Ash, further away,
but that pales in comparison to the effects of a love of NATO.
There are about 1500 active volcanoes on earth and each of them
could create 11 NATO during an eruption.
And what's even more dangerous than a volcano creating a
lava NATO, all those volcanoes erupting at the same time.
But that's a story for another. What if
[inaudible].